si ok on a eu l'une des plus longues
alertes aériennes cette nuit et la durée
près de 7 heures alors peu après minuit
elle a commencé donc on a eu les sirènes
tout au dessus de la ville puis plus
rien pendant plusieurs heures dans la
capitale alors que ailleurs dans le pays
dans le pays il y avait déjà des
explosions jusqu'à ce moment à 5h30
heure de Kiev ou une explosion à retenti
dans le centre-ville elle aurait touché
une infrastructure essentielle une
infrastructure électrique en tout cas
ici à Kiev il y a eu deux blessés il n'y
a pas eu de mort à déplorer pour
l'instant en revanche le réseau
électrique a été touché avec 15% des
foyers qui sont privés d'électricité 40%
qui sont privés de chauffage également
après après cette frappe et vous l'avez
mentionné ces frappe ont touché tout le
pays plus de 15 fois elles sont tombées
sur la région de harki elles sont
tombées également dans l'ouest du pays à
vivre à ivanoflanquis donc c'est
vraiment le côté ouest de l'Ukraine qui
qui n'est pas en général touché en tout
cas pas aussi fréquemment que l'est la
défense ukrainienne a réussi à
neutraliser 34 des 48 missiles de
croisière envoyé contre l'Ukraine le
problème de cette défense ukrainienne
c'est qu'elle n'est pour l'instant pas
en mesure de contrer les missiles
hypersoniques de type kinshas de type
C300 qui sont également utilisés par par
l'armée russe et ce genre d'homicie qui
cause le plus de dégâts qui s'abat
également sur des habitations
rappelez-vous il y a deux mois le 14
janvier dernier un missile de ce type
avait
coûté la vie à 46 personnes en
s'écrasant sur un bâtiment résidentiel
dans la ville de nitro
parlez-nous peut-être des conséquences
du climat que faire régner par ses
campagnes de frappe massive la Russie à
la population
ukrainienne dans quel état sont les
Ukrainiens ce matin
éprouvés ici à Kiev pour vous donner un
exemple il y a énormément de gens à qui
j'ai pu écrire ce matin qui en fait
n'avait même pas pris la peine
finalement de d'aller dans un abri et la
nuit dernière il était très tard lorsque
l'alarme a sonné ces alarmes sonne de
manière presque quotidienne les gens
apprennent malheureusement à vivre avec
en revanche tout le monde s'est réveillé
à 5h30 lors de cette explosion c'est
c'est très dur à vivre pour les
Ukrainiens je parlais également avec
avec une amie qui vit à de Nièvre admis
pro pardon
qui a été vraiment affecté la nuit
dernière en entendant des drones
kamikazes volés au dessus de la ville en
entendant plusieurs explosions c'est
malheureusement le quotidien des
millions d'ukrainien depuis depuis plus
d'un an maintenant